I guess this is the part where I make a
cliche joke about the language of
romance.
You should pay him and you'll have a
nice Maliki.
Mia Maslovian.
Okay.
Cut cliche.
Joke over.
Finished.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today I'm going to be talking about the
romance languages,
not the language of romance,
the romance languages.
Why should you care about the romance
languages?
Wealth?
The most important romance languages are
French,
Spanish,
Italian,
Portuguese,
and Romanian.
They are some of the most widely spoken
languages in Europe and some of them are
spoken widely around the entire world.
There are 800 million native speakers of
romance languages around the world.
That's why you should care.
They are a group of languages that
belong to the Italax subfamily of the
Indo European language family.
It's Alec languages or languages
originating and what is now it's a
illegal,
what is the captain.